what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
discussing one of my favorite characters
in demon slayer the Mitsui lover himself
Obon ie guru the snake pillar as far as
design goes he always has a pet snake
around him he has two different colored
eyes and he has ninja-esque bandages
that often cover his mouth I don't know
if you can stand out much more than that
I'm talking about ego row today because
you guys voted for him via Instagram
stories at anime uproar you can now vote
for who the next video will be about
make sure to go to Instagram at anime
uproar and vote as soon as possible
because stories only last for 24 hours
make sure you're following us there
because we regularly do these kinds of
votes as soon as we get 5,000 likes on
this video I will start on the next one
ASAP so smash that like button and share
this video with your friends if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell
because you will miss future videos if
you don't as usual there will be manga
spoilers in this video I have to look at
all the relevant info to determine
exactly how strong a guru is now without
further ado let's jump into it so let's
take a look at this lovestruck snake
guys develop and throughout the story so
he can get a sense of the evolution of
his strength interestingly enough a girl
was born in a family of all women and it
was said that it had been about 370
years since a man was born into the
family immediately guro was locked in a
cage the woman always brought him tons
of food and were nice to him you know
besides the whole keeping him in a cage
his whole life part it was at the age of
12 where he was finally pulled out of
the cage and brought to a demon she was
a hybrid between a human and a snake it
turns out that iguras family treated
this snake demon as a kind of God and
gave their own babies to the demon as an
offering in exchange the snake demon
would not kill all of that and even let
them steal the wealth of other people
she killed so in this very messed-up way
he grows family became wealthy the only
reason II guro wasn't eaten right away
was because he was a rare male and had
different colored eyes the snake demon
took an interest in him and wanted to
let him grow to a more filling size but
even at 12 he was still too small so the
snake didn't want to eat him yet
ironically agarose weak frame actually
saved him still he didn't get away
unscathed the woman of the family
obey the state demon and cut a girl's
mouth so it would look like the snake
demons mouth then the demon drank the
blood that came from the wound and agura
was sent back to his cage now knowing
the disturbing truth his family was
beyond corrupt and he was being fattened
up just to be fed to a snake demon he
eventually managed to escape using a
hairpin to scratch away a section of his
self he was a nervous wreck every day he
was scratching away at the cage worried
that they'd discover what he was doing
a snake kibou dama who came in and
became his only friend it is the same
snake he carries with him to this day
as soon as he could he squeezed his tiny
body through the opening in the cave she
created and ran the snake demon caught
up to him but luckily a girl was saved
by the flame pillar at the time in all
likelihood this was cured Rouladen
Goku's that the flame pillar brought him
together with his only surviving cousin
his cousin though was mad at him because
eager to escape the snake demon killed
the other fifty family members his
cousin completely blamed egora and even
shoved him obviously a girl was not to
blame he just tried to survive and the
family never should have been working
with the snake team in the first place
but he still internalized a sense of
guilt over what happened and he
continues to feel weighed down by the
presence of the fifty people who died
because of his actions because of this
backstory eager to develop the belief
that his family and as a result his
blood was filthy and corrupt and that he
added to that pre-existing corruption by
saving himself at the expense of the
rest of his family he grew to feel that
his sins were too great for him to live
a normal life he turned all his rage on
demons risking his life fighting them
and saving others helped him feel like a
slightly better person however no matter
how many people he saved he continued to
believe that the only way could possibly
hope to be cleansed of his sins was
through death that is where ego is
coming from he was too weak and tiny for
the snake demon to even want to eat him
yet he was extremely scared and all he
could do was run for his life he was
helpless them had to be saved by the
flame pillar then he joined the demon
Slayers and became stronger he met and
fell in love with meet suti the love
pillar - but he couldn't reveal his
feelings to her because he felt like he
didn't deserve her by the time we were
first introduced to ego during the story
he is a completely different person that
he used
nine years have passed since he escaped
from that snake demon and he is now 21
years old physically speaking he is the
second weakest pillar after Shinobu
according to data book but as we know
overall strength is never a matter of
purely physical strength despite his
lacking physical strength
Iguodala immediately seems confident in
his overall strength he berates fellow
pillar Gill who took out lower moon five
Rui
like it was nothing showing that he's
not afraid of gives strength at all meet
suti comments that agudo is as coolly
menacing as a snake and that he's
reliable another hint at his strength
meat so he also wants to marry a guy
stronger than her so the heart that pops
up in the manga while she's looking at
ego could suggest that ego is stronger
than her and thus a potential love
interest when conjurer tries to stop
sending me from hurting that Zuko eager
to hits him temporarily taking away his
ability to breathe and move
gu ends up taking his elbow off of tan
judo you it'll quickly releases his hand
from G whose grip without a problem but
he is irritated that GU would get
involved that is the first time we see
eager oh he doesn't appear to be afraid
of anyone and he completely
incapacitates our protagonist in a
second later eager to upon hearing that
and Goku died against upper moon three
Icaza remarks that he can't believe it
suggesting that in Goku was strong even
by his standards this remark can be seen
as suggesting that and Goku was stronger
than a guru at this point in the story
later when the sound pillar tengan with
tangelos any two in dusky and a Zuko's
help beat supper moon 6e guru is not
impressed he asks him what the Sam
pillar was thinking losing his left arm
and eye against the weakest upper moon
he also looks down on his decision to
retire clearly a guru is implying that
upper moon six would not give him nearly
as much trouble since tengan needed all
that help - we can reasonably assume
that ego is significantly stronger than
tengan at this point
drink the pillar training arc eager to
ties up demon slayer members for the
crime of weakness ego clearly is harsh
when it comes to a standard for strength
he ties up the members that upset him
and then uses them as obstacles that
tonzura needs to avoid hitting it takes
a whole four days but eventually
tensional slices off iguras kimono style
jacket and moves on to the next round
however throughout the training Iger
made sure to tell
to stay away from his precious Mitsui
it's funny even though a guru won't ask
out me sorry he still gets jealous and
doesn't want anyone else to do it either
it's also interesting that it took
tension of four days to just cut a
girl's clothing
well he got solid hits on the extremely
strong Santa me multiple times although
he didn't have to weep through tied up
demons their members with son Amin now
we jump to the most recent and relevant
parts in the manga drink dimensional
infinity fortress arc eager no runs in
to meet suti and together they fight up
her moon for knocking a euro takes
charge and gives me to the advice he
says and I quote as long as we don't
know our opponents abilities let's watch
closely think hard and proceed calmly
and me to the agrees showing that she is
willing to follow his lead eager finds
nakamise blood demon art which lets her
control the fortress around them to be
really annoying it's not deadly and ego
has no problem staying alive but getting
close enough to kill vacuum is nearly
impossible
at one point you should know uses
genjutsu and brainwashes naka may and
thus moves on into thinking that meets
to the ante guru are dead immediately I
doubted this vision because we haven't
really seen eager to shine at this point
and it wouldn't make sense that the two
went from being annoyed by a non deadly
power to being killed by that power
my hunch turned out to be right and
suddenly Mitsui and guru show up to help
tangental NGU fight moves on you guru
it's quite impressive throughout the
fight against moves on even compared to
Sena me and Guillaume a who show up
later
keep in mind out of the pillars present
ego is the last to manifest his Demon
Slayer mark during chapter 189 before
that the others have all awakened their
Demon Slayer marks and this is important
to note because of how well ego is
keeping up with them without a demon
slayer mark for instance meet suti who
has awakened the demon slayer mark
reveals that she is relying on intuition
and luck to dodge moves on at one point
ego without a demon mark doesn't just
fare better than meet suti with a demon
mark
he even shields gilma at the same time
although he reveals that he can't keep
shielding him for long meat so his luck
runs out and she gets some serious
injuries from moves on you go to helps
her get to a safe place and make sure
she gets proper treatment afterwards he
jumps back into battle he wants to die
beating moves on he hopes that he'll be
reborn with different blood and only
then
will he be worthy to ask out Mitsui even
without a demon sir mark he's holding
his own alongside sodomy and Yomi Mouzon
is even impressed by how eager to kicks
away his limbs as soon as he cuts him to
prevent immediate regeneration GU is
actually the first to loose a sword
Yomi ain't eager to defend you from
Mulan's attack while sodomy passes his
sword back to him
gu himself is a skilled pillar with a
demon slayer mark who is arguably
stronger than Mitsui and eager Oh seems
to be fighting at a higher level than
him even without a demon ser mark not
only is eager to doing this well without
a mark
since he's small the poison that
accompanies Mulan's attacks is also
spreading the fastest within him yet
he's helping his fellow pillars rather
than slowing them down
luckily Tamayo scat saves the day and
heals everyone from the poison then
remembering Mui Chiu a story of how he
turned his blade red eager grips his
sword hard and it turns red while Demon
Slayer marks finally appear on his body
eager I was like the last living pillar
to manifest a Demon Slayer mark so you
know it will be accompanied by a
significant power upgrade anime do often
save the best for last because that's
the most entertaining way to do it just
think about how s Kannur was the last
cent introduced in the seven deadly sins
as I'm writing this video chapter 1 Chan
89 is the last chapter out so we can
only speculate as to how powerful ego
will be however the fact that he could
do so well without a demon ser mark and
keep up with the other pillars means
that with a demon ser mark and red blade
he's probably going to be right up there
with full power Guillaume and Sunnah me
Yoma is known as the strongest pillar so
it is probably too early to assume that
ego will be more powerful than him but
he is at least top 3 after this and he
could very well step ahead of sana me
furthermore if he is the only one
currently with a red blade he will be
the most useful in this battle even more
useful than Gillman chances are that the
other weapons will turn red now that ego
Rose has but if they don't
ego will be the MVP because red blades
represent the power of the Sun when
you're DT the strongest demons haircut
moves on with his red blade moves on had
trouble regenerating if all weapons
become red after this upgrade ego is
likely to be in the top two strongest
pillars and if the others don't turn red
that he'll be the strongest and most
effective fighter against Musa
whatever approach
mangaka ends up taking ego has proved
that he is definitely stronger than
Mitsui which means he meets me to these
requirements for a love interest now he
just has to survive so he can confess
his feelings to her in this lifetime and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching remember if we get
5,000 likes I will start working on the
next video ASAP so smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else
you'll miss future videos I will set up
a vote via Instagram stories for who the
next video will be about go follow us
there at anime up roar link in the
description and you can help decide what
videos I make in the future a special
thank you goes out to our patrons on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole cos ASCII alpha do angel
Cruz and team Sparky 65 and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephan and Radha alo Lana 10
Maddy Mac 239 makoto-kun the world
steelers tyson Kirino and the school bus
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon calm an Emir Pro and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to her private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]